Ronnie brought to my attention this
morning that Sal has worn hats to work
the past two days and everyone asked me
if I noticed and I never look at Sal so
of course I confronted Sal about this
what we've learned is the reason that
Sal is wearing caps to work is because
his hair cannot be exposed to light
anymore and that is because
he is doing a hair treatment
51 light sources including 21 laser
diodes and 30 LED lights are strapped
into a helmet on his head shooting these
Rays into his hair follicles in hopes of
growing them now we've done a lot of
research he has a full head of hair all
I know is that the contraption and
Gary's bringing it in now it's a bicycle
helmet
the thing is that your hair it warns you
during this treatment program that if
your hair is exposed to light strange
things can happen
and this is why Sal is wearing the ball
cap to work every day you have to do it
for a week no lights for a week on your
hair I mean Sal come here you're like a
why because I want my hair to look
good because well you have hair yeah
what are you worried about oh light got
on it
you're stupid don't you think if
somebody figured out a way to grow hair
that it would be it would be all it
would be the front page of every
newspaper for a year well I might be the
first poster child you never know okay I
mean I use your head you don't know what
that what this is beats the out of
me yeah okay it looks like a cool
Contraption so I'm giving it a shot put
it on your head
have you felt any overheating Sal
because it appears that it could
overheat your head do you hear do you
feel your head you have no nerves in my
brain I hope you go bald from it
you've got such a lovely full head of
hair why are you worrying and these
things massage in and they've worked the
follicles for people are you losing your
hair a little bit here and there I I I'm
a little I'm very self-conscious about
it I constantly leave your hair alone
okay I fall asleep with it and you know
what I can't hear my wife put this thing
on so it's pretty good
it's fantastic right right oh my God I'm
giving it a shot I don't know all right
turn to your uh to your left